a week-long ceasefire was meant to stop
this
fighting between the Sudanese Army and
the paramilitary rapid support forces
and even though it's failed to stop
fighting and was described as imperfect
by U.S and Saudi mediators the warring
parties extended it for another five
days we are very concerned
with the security and peace of our own
fellow citizens this is a priority in
our policy Whenever there is a chance to
extend
the ceasefire we will not hesitate a
second but unfortunately we have agreed
the first time the second time
five times but next day it was the
Rebellion Force which violates the
ceasefire and they commit gross
violations
explosions and gunfire were heard in
parts of the capital Khartoum and plumes
of smoke a new daily scene could be seen
Rising following an airstrike the
fighting has displaced over 1.3 million
people since mid-april
Millions remain in hartum in desperate
need of humanitarian assistance the
ceasefire was meant to open humanitarian
corridors so they could be helped but
while some Aid has been brought in
organizers say the ongoing violence is
making it difficult for them to reach
all those who need it
the fighting has affected the largest
orphanage in Sudan
since the start of the fighting the
center has been without water and power
most of the staff have left due to the
violence supplies to the orphanage have
been disrupted at least 50 Children
including babies have died as a result
this is the call of help
Humanity peace and hope hope for normal
and a better life for the orphans who
are trapped in cartoon because of the
war and throughs violation
I'm standing here in this situation for
the second time calling your conscious
and compassion to save more than 300
child their age between days and years
suffering every day from lack of feeding
supplements proper Medical Care and
mental health support
foreign
hospitals and homes remain occupied in
hartum despite the ceasefire calling for
them to be free of the Armed parties and
for those who've been able to leave the
hope for an end to the war remains
we used to live in the city of damasin
then the war resumed in Khartoum so we
became displaced again and moved toward
madani we are currently staying hay with
great patience and difficulty due to the
war if the war stops we will return to
Khartoum we hope for security and peace
in our country
but those left behind in Khartoum fear
even if the ceasefire is extended
fighting will continue Heber Morgan Al
Jazeera on durman